yes
I made it
welcome to my new office my very Barren
empty room hopefully it doesn't Echo too
much go too much
but it's in Japan
I would show you outside but I don't
want to dox myself right away at least
after three years after three long years
I am finally here oh my God if you saw
my video a few months ago where I was
ranting about how this attempt to move
how difficult it's been at that time I
didn't think we were gonna make it even
so the fact that I'm here it just feels
unbelievable it still hasn't even sunk
in yet every time I wake up I'm like
where am I
why is why is the weather nice I don't
get it but everything went super smooth
the dogs are
um they're getting used to being here
turns out jet lag is a thing for dogs as
well
which made transitioning really
difficult because they kept waking up
super early and but they're doing great
and I'm really happy for it we're doing
really great as well honestly though
first few days was kind of shocking
first it was like we made it to Japan
oh we're in Japan
the [ __ ]
we don't speak the language
did we just move to another country
where you don't speak the language half
across the globe
in our 30s
with no real goal or Reason
yeah I guess we did I guess I should
explain why we made this move because it
is a bit kind of an odd one usually when
people come here it's for a job or to
study and things like that we're here
mainly I guess you could say this
because we really enjoy it here every
time I talk about Japan people for some
reason seem to want to bombard me of
well did you know Japan is really high
this or that or it's not I'm not trying
to romanticize this country like it's
this perfect thing but it's just that we
really like it here we feel really
comfortable here and we really enjoy it
the whole reason of the move is mainly
that we want to have different
experiences you know you live once and
this is something that we wanted to do
and that we knew we were able to do and
yes it's scary and kind of crazy but
I don't think that should stop you and
that's our reason the pros of cons of
different countries and cities and
places it all depends on who you are and
what you value and and where you are in
life and if things can turn out
differently anyway you know Japan is
famous for having super low crime rate
our house still got broken into you know
I know there will be challenges along
this way and I know it's not going to be
easy but we are ready and we're prepared
for it and so yeah because to be fair
this move did come with a big sacrifice
of moving further away from family even
though we spent a ton of years apart
from them already the living friends
behind that we've gone grown really
really close to hopefully we can still
attain stay in touch I mean modern
technology makes that happen but it's
still tough and not to mention the whole
process we were planning this move at
the same time as our wedding because we
felt like we wanted to speed things
along as much as possible uh see how
that got for us we knew it was going to
be difficult and it was difficult but
then when covet happened and there was
just no updates for two years about what
the situation of people entering the
country was going to be and honestly it
was the most frustrating thing I've ever
had to endure uh maybe you can say that
means I'm privileged but it was awful
and I never want to do that again
I think I think the best way to put is
if I knew everything before this move no
way I would make this move no same
person would would go through all of
this just to move country it's just it's
just too much and despite how difficult
it's been and all the challenges and
sacrifices with time and stress and
money and oh God
I don't want that at all to weigh me
down I'm here now I'm super happy I'm
super excited every day we discover new
things that are it's just great and we
love it uh like I said the dogs are
settling in really well and uh
just feel really good I'm super excited
for the future and what else to do here
I think a lot of people thought maybe he
will move to Japan and then he'll retire
because I think people already assume
I've been stepping down on the amount of
videos that I've uploaded so far I don't
feel like it
if anything I want to keep making videos
kind of the same way I have been I'm
sharing stuff that I feel like sharing
doing projects that I want to really do
and not just upload for the sake of
uploading uploading daily for 12 years
has been great but I don't want to do it
for another 12 years okay
as this seems like a sad way of living
to me I don't know there are other
things I want to experience in life I
want to be here in Japan and not
at the back of my mind worrying about an
upload every single day you know but I
do want to bring you guys along like
doing Vlogs and other kind of stuff like
that but yeah this is my temporary setup
for now I'm recording this on my laptop
I can't buy a desktop yet because to buy
a desktop you need a Japanese telephone
number to order and I don't have that
and to get a Japanese telephone number I
need to register at the Town Hall and I
can't register the town hall because we
had to quarantine because of covert
coming here so
there's already a lot of challenges not
to mention the language barrier I'm
still learning Japanese obviously but
konichiwa
I got a long way to go but I think
things will just get easier as we go and
it makes it fun honestly we obviously
took a jet to get here and I feel like
maybe people will wonder about that or
ask questions it's not the kind of if
you know me that's not the kind of thing
I would normally do I wouldn't even
consider it if I didn't feel like I
didn't have any any other option there
was so many difficult with bringing our
dogs Edgar is a little too big to bring
him in a cabin and bringing a short
snouted dog who already is famous for
not being able to breathe well bringing
that through the cargo
it just didn't feel Fair risking my
dog's health just because I want to move
country so we looked into I think I
called every single Airline there is but
most of them have a restriction on the
sizes and they he was he's just too big
for the cabin and I think honestly
though I've seen a ton of videos on
YouTube where people fly their dogs in
their cabin and other pugs similar size
to Edgar and I think if we did bring him
it probably would have been totally fine
but there was so much riding on this
move happening at this exact exact date
for for all kinds of reasons that it
just seemed like the best way to do it
and maybe people have opinions about it
but
[ __ ] I don't know what else to do
before it was awesome I really enjoyed
it it's the kind of experience you do
once in a lifetime and I I uh I'll never
forget it it was so cool they felt like
a dream honestly the fact that it
finally happened we were sitting there
on our way to Japan after all this
amount of stress and work it finally
happened and here we are
I also gotta thank you guys because I
shared my video and about my
frustrations about not being able to
come here and there was no updates and
so many people were so cheering us on
like you guys really wanted this to
happen for us it is a dream for us and I
never considered giving up on something
so many times
you know we didn't move here for other
people but I'd be lying if I said it
didn't help a little bit at least the
fact that people really wanted this for
us and that I really appreciate that you
guys carry in that way so thank you it's
been a while since I've been this
excited for the future I can't wait to
see what next insane chapter that we've
done will lead I think me and Marsha
have always taken really big leaps and
risks that have at the time been really
scary but they've they've always paid
off this feels like the kind of video I
want to react to in like five years
to see how it all worked out but yeah I
look forward to shayla's Journey with
you guys and thank you for watching I'll
see you in the next video